what's that believe nations so we cross
550,000 YouTube subscribers thank you
for that I've made over 3,600 public
videos and over 4,000 videos total if
you include the private and unlisted
ones I often get asked by people about
the journey about the climb and people
often think that I am naturally gifted
or talented at this because all they see
is where I'm at now as opposed to where
I was when I started and so I thought
it'd be fun to go back and look at the
very first youtube video that I uploaded
from April of 2009 so 7 years ago just
to show you guys how far I've come but
also hopefully serve as inspiration for
you guys because the points are great
the story is good but I am super nervous
I'm sitting down I'm in a suit I'm
trying to memorize my lines
thankfully I partnered up with one of my
friends mark Drager was actually in my
book you're one word running is one word
of extraordinary
[Music]
beep help me with some of the editing
and filming on that video so it looks
professional but I was just terrible and
so I thought you guys would enjoy the
look back and I'm curious to hear what
you think hello and welcome to another
edition of modeling the Masters my name
is Evan Carmichael and today we're going
to be talking about the famous
entrepreneur Walt Disney and how you can
model his strategies to achieve success
with your business
[Music]
[Music]
everyone knows Walt Disney for his
movies theme parks and cast of
characters what most people don't know
is when he first started out he had no
money he had to live in his office
because he couldn't afford rent for an
apartment and he survived on a diet of
cold beans because he couldn't afford
food by committing to his business and
sticking with it he was now able to
build a business that has almost 40
billion dollars in revenue so today
we're going to look at three lessons
that you can learn for wealth is and
success and apply it into your company
lesson number one is find something that
you love Walt Disney grew up in the
early 1900s on a farm in Missouri and
developed a passion for drawing so much
so that one of his neighbors actually
paid him to draw some cartoons of his
horses when Walt Disney got to school he
found that he was a good student but he
really enjoyed doodling as opposed to
paying attention to his teachers he
connected with one of his high school
papers and started drawing patriotic
cartoons for the school paper
when he was 16 though he found that
school just wasn't for him so he dropped
out join the Red Cross learn to become
an ambulance driver and actually was
shipped to France to become an ambulance
driver over there he couldn't lose that
passion for drawing and cartooning and
he ended up plastering his ambulance
full of different cartoon creations that
he had made people knew him on the
street because he was an ambulance
driver with all the different cartoons
plastered on his ambulance
he decided that cartooning was for him
he was going to be an artist and return
to America to start his career as an
artist
so lesson number one really is make sure
you have that strong passion for your
business if you don't really love it
it's going to be hard to succeed as a
business owner if you look at any famous
entrepreneur and why they serve the
business it wasn't for the money money
comes when you're really passionate
about what you're doing so think about
what is it that you do in your spare
time what do you really enjoy doing what
gets you going in the morning what are
your hobbies and how can you turn those
into a potential business opportunity
lesson number two is push the boundaries
Walt Disney first made his mark in 1934
when he proposed making a feature-length
animation which had never been done
before it was called Snow White
it took three years to make you went a
hundred percent over budget people
thought he was crazy for doing it he ran
out of money at the end and had to
actually act out the last scenes of the
movie for his bankers to get the money
he needed to close and finish the movie
it ended up being a huge success it was
the biggest hit of the year he won an
Academy Award for it and it was a
financial gain for him Walt Disney's
next big project was Disneyland a 330
acre project out in California a theme
park which had nothing to do with his
movies people thought it was crazy again
why would you do this what tie does it
have to your movie business but he had a
vision he was determined to make it
happen and again it was a big success
for him then he went on to open up the
Walt Disney World in Florida and the
company was able to open up different
theme parks around the world so the
message for entrepreneurs here is push
the boundaries you need to do something
different to get your company noticed as
a small entrepreneur there's so much
competition it's so difficult to get on
people's radar screens and make them pay
attention to you so you have to do
something that's going to get you notice
something that will help you stand out
from the crowd so what is it that will
be your equivalent of a Snow White
something that's never been done before
it's really going to get you notice and
get the attention paid to your business
lesson number three is stay top of mind
Walt Disney did everything he could to
make sure people kept remembering the
Walt Disney name he did a lot of
advertising as an example so we did TV
campaigns direct mail campaigns print
ads he even did grocery store coupon
cutout so when you're at the grocery
store you're thinking about Walt Disney
he was also a pioneer in merchandising
so whenever a new feature film came out
that was a Walt Disney production you
would also be able to buy all the
merchandise that went along with it
today while Disney is known not only for
its movies but its TV stations theme
parks dolls toys games and a whole host
of other merchandise so the lesson for
entrepreneurs is stay top of mind you
need to do whatever you can to make sure
your customers are always thinking about
you the easiest way to grow a business
is to sell more to your existing
customers the hardest way to grow a
business is to go and try to find new
so do whatever you can to make sure your
customers are always thinking about you
you're the first person that comes to
mind when they're thinking about your
product or service and it's the best way
to be able to grow your business Walt
Disney is an entrepreneurial legend
who's built up one of the most
recognized companies in the world but
remember when he first got started he
had no money nobody believed in him he
had to live out of his office because he
couldn't afford an apartment and he
survived on a diet of cold beans because
he couldn't afford other food by
following his lessons though you too can
achieve entrepreneurial success so
remember find something you love push
the boundaries and stay top of mind I
hope you've enjoyed this episode of
modeling the masters to learn more about
Walt Disney and his entrepreneurial
success you can visit our website at
Evan Carmichael com and you can also
check out our blogs which is listed
below I also want to take this
opportunity to thank Fanta media for the
great work they've done in producing
this video and I hope you'll join us for
the next episode of modeling the Masters
[Music]
so thank you guys so much for watching
that is embarrassing to watch every time
I look at that video like oh it's so bad
actually take that video down but the
points are still good and I think that
it helps show the climb in the journey
and if you follow along on the thirty
six hundred plus videos you'll see
gradual slow and steady improvement over
the years so that's my very first
youtube video hopefully you guys got
some kind of inspiration or at least a
good laugh out of it and I'm curious to
hear from you guys what is your YouTube
story what do you remember about your
first video compared to where you're at
now and maybe that's only two videos ago
or maybe that's a hundred videos ago but
talking about your growth and your climb
I think it could be good to just get it
out but also serve as an inspiration to
others so that we're not just looking at
us compared to somebody else's you know
middle or end but going back to realize
hey everybody started at the start
everybody kind of sucked at the start
and got better still in celos so I'd
love to hear your story please share it
in the comments below I also want to
give a quick shout out to Manju Nash you
know I thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word I hope
you enjoying it and I really really
really appreciate it so thank you guys
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is let's love
I'll see you soon